une prise de poste un changement de
stratégie d'entreprise
un rachat un licenciement monter une
activité et devenir entrepreneur qu'on
le veuille ou non nous sommes tout le
temps exposées à des pertes de repères
et quand ça se passe mal ça peut nous
emmener très loin fatigue épuisement des
pressions ou même burnout et dans ces
cas-là on aimerait bien avoir un repère
aujourd'hui je vous en propose un qui
s'appelle le voyage du héros et l'
avantage c'est qu'il a une fin heureuse
alors déjà c'est quoi un repère un
repère c'est un élément qui permet de
s'orienter dans sa vie dans ses choix ou
simplement sur son trajet ça peut être
par exemple un parent ou un professeur
qui nous inspire et à qui nous avons
envie de ressembler ça peut être des
valeurs qui nous parlent et qui nous
permettent de nous orienter dans nos
choix de vie et de déterminer ce qui est
bien ou mal pour nous ça peut être aussi
tout simplement des panneaux de
signalisation lyon grenoble et ça peut
être aussi une séquence repères c'est à
dire une séquence d'événements qui
s'enchaînent toujours de la même manière
quand on vient en france le matin le
soleil apparaît le soir le soleil
disparaît chaque jour que nous vivons en
france nous savons que nous allons vivre
cela
sauf lors des éclipses mais au moyen âge
on ne le savait pas et pour le coup les
éclipses provoquer de véritables moments
de panique tout changement de situation
est par essence une perte de repères on
passe d'un monde connu à un monde moins
connus voire un monde inconnu comme les
héros dans les films se déroule par
exemple c'est d'ailleurs là qu'est né le
voyage du héros en 1949
joseph campbell écrit un livre qui
s'appelle le héros aux mille visages
en tant que professeur anthropologue et
spécialiste de mythologie comparer il a
étudié toutes ces histoires de manière à
en dégager la trame commune
cela donne un livre d'une richesse
extraordinaire le premier en son genre
un véritable trésor un certain george
lucas ce le découvre et à la lumière de
celui ci réécrit totalement le scénario
star wars
au vu des aventures de luke skywalker et
leur succès on pourrait penser que oui
il ya bien une trame commune mais celle
de caen bel et bien trop complexe et
absolument pas utilisable un étudiant en
cinéma du nom de christopher voeckler
découvre aussi se livrer s'y plonge
il en fait une synthèse de cette page
simple et utilisable il l'appelle
d'ailleurs un guide pratique du héros
aux mille visages de joseph campbell
quelques personnes lisent ces pages et
une rumeur se répand
quelqu'un aurait élucider le secret des
bonnes histoires et ce secret s'appelle
le voyage du héros à l'époque internet
n'existe pas le fax non plus et pourtant
c'est cette page dactylographiée vont
faire le tour de l'île woods à une
vitesse impressionnante
aujourd'hui encore le voyage du héros et
la bible est le repaire de nombreux
scénaristes le roi lion titanic matrix
et même les choristes en suivre la trame
le voyage du héros des coupes toute
histoire en 12 étapes 12 étapes comme
autant de points de repères je suis
psycho praticiens et consultants et ce
qui m'intéresse ici c'est que les
professionnels de l'accompagnement ont
perçu que ces douze étapes étaient des
repaires dans tout changement personnel
et que nous les retrouvons dans nos vies
à nous cette vie dont nous sommes le
héros alors ça c'est la théorie
maintenant j'ai voulu voir si ça
marchait vraiment j'ai voulu vérifier
prendre un cas concret
j'ai choisi une femme entrepreneur robin
chase que j'avais découvert suite un toc
j'ai fait quelques recherches sur
internet j'ai vu des articles et des
interviews de manière à retracer son
parcours
voici le résultat de mon enquête qui met
en parallèle son histoire et le voyage
du héros étape 1 le monde ordinaire le
héros nous est présenté à l'origine
ainsi que le monde dans lequel il vit
robin chase et fille et fille de
diplomate américain enfants elle vit en
arabie saoudite où l'eau est rare
sa mère est la seule américaine à
utiliser l'eau du bain pour arroser les
plantes
de là naît la conscience écologique de
robin et aussi la naissance de son
engagement pour la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
adulte elle travaille dans la santé elle
se marie et elle
trois enfants puis voulant évoluer dans
sa carrière professionnelle elle passa
un billet étape 2 l'appel de l'aventuré
laventure vient frapper à la porte du
héros en 1999
robin prends un café avec une amie cet
ami lui suggère l'idée d'ouvrir un
service de partage de voitures aux
etats-unis partager une voiture réduire
son bilan carbone
robin est intéressé étape 3 le refus de
l'appel le héros n'est pas encore prêt à
accepter laventure robin se dit qu'elle
n'a jamais fait cela et en même temps
elle se dit que 199 l'économie du
partage c'est pas vraiment ça alors elle
demande à son ami
mais est ce que tu crois qu aux états
unis ça peut vraiment marché étape 4
le mentor une personne extérieure ou une
connaissance extérieur vient donner aux
héros le coup de pouce qui lui permet
d'avancer
son ami lui dit j'ai vécu en allemagne
plusieurs années où ce service est déjà
en place ça marche vraiment bien
étape 5 le passage le héros a maintenant
toutes les informations et décide
d'entrer dans le nouveau monde
il a accepté l'aventuré les deux femmes
se regarde
elles sont d'accord elles se serrent la
main elles vont faire 50 50
zipcar entreprise de partage de voitures
est né étape 6 tests découverte
le héros a accepté l'aventuré rentrer
dans un nouveau monde mais il ne connaît
pas les règles de ce nouveau monde
il doit donc faire des tests et à
prendre qui sont ses alliés et ses
ennemis robin se met donc à travailler
et se rend compte de tout ce que sa
demande demander des fonds mettre en
place un business plan tout ce genre de
choses
elle se rend compte aussi que le 50/50
ne sera pas vraiment respectée et
finalement les seize heures par jour
c'est elle qui va les faire tout seul
étape 7
le héros se prépare à affronter ses
ennemis pour la première fois petit à
petit
robin travail et des coûts ce que ça
implique alors qu'elle pensait que ce
projet lui allait lui permettre d'être
maman elle se rend compte que elle ne
peut pas s'occuper comme elle veut de
ses enfants de 6 9 et 12 ans et elle se
rend compte aussi que finalement zipcar
est un moyen pragmatique de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
étape 8 l'épreuve
le héros doit affronter sa plus grande
peur en montrant un changement profond
avant l'été 2000 robinet de ses propres
mots le plus horrible parents qui soient
elle a besoin de s'occuper de ses
enfants c'est viscéral et en même temps
elle voit tout le bénéfice qu'il peut y
avoir à partager des voitures elle ne
peut lâcher aucun des deux et pourtant
les deux sont incompatibles
c'est alors qu'elle va avoir une idée
hors des clous elle demande à son mari
de quitter son travail pour s'occuper
des enfants
il accepte robin est donc rassuré et
peut lancer icare étape 9 la récompense
le héros a passé l'épreuve avec succès
et reçoit en récompense un objet ou une
compétence en juin 2010 picard est lancé
robin est maintenant une chef
d'entreprise compétentes qui sait
prendre des décisions personnelles et
professionnelles pour aller dans le bon
sens établissent leur tour le héros se
préparent à l'affrontement final
l'entreprise est lancé les clients
commencent à arriver en septembre 2000
l'entreprise vers entre douze et quinze
voitures et compte 400 membres et appose
l'affrontement final le héros peut vivre
ou mourir
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent
résurrection et alors robin se rend
compte qu'elle s'est trompé dans ses
calculs
elle ferme la porte de son bureau et
elle pleure elle se dit qu'elle a vendu
un mensonge
elle se dit qu'elle a fait une promesse
qu'elle ne peut pas tenir mais n'a pas
le choix elle doit augmenter les prix
alors elle prend son ordinateur
elle commence un email pour les 400
membres qui dit en substance
j'ai foiré je suis désolé nous ne
pouvons pas continuer avec un prix aussi
bas
nous allons augmenter les prix de 25%
elle envoie lebel et elle rentre chez
elle
le lendemain quand elle revient au
travail elle est morte de peur quand
elle arrive un employé lui saute dessus
il a les deux pouces en l'air ils ont
reçu 21 une réponse sur les vingt-et-une
19 10 vous savez on trouve avec le
service n'était pas assez serré puis
vous inquiétez pas on adore ce que vous
faites deux sont des mails de colère
robin prend son téléphone et les appels
l'un puis l'autre est leur explique que
l'entreprise ne peut pas survivre si
elle n'augmente pas les prix les deux
restent finalement et l'un d'eux va même
leur faire une super publicité étape 12
l'élixir le héros victorieuse célèbre sa
victoire et partage avec le monde sa
nouvelle connaissance aujourd'hui
zipcar gère onze mille voitures et à 760
1000 membres répartis entre l'amérique
du nord et l'angleterre
depuis robin chase a quitté l'entreprise
et a fondé deux autres entreprises qui
font aussi du partage de voitures go
locaux et buzzcar disponible en france
aujourd'hui
robin chase continue à oeuvrer à travers
le système de partage de voitures pour
réduire les émissions carbone et lutter
ainsi de manière pragmatique contre le
réchauffement climatique
fin de l'histoire alors vous je sais pas
mais moi j'ai été assez surpris c'est à
dire que quand même ça colle pas mal les
deux et même si certains passages sont
assez courts on retrouve absolument les
12 étapes du voyage du héros commençait
une nouvelle mission démarrer une
nouvelle entreprise démarrer une
nouvelle aventure professionnelle quelle
qu'elle soit
tout cela nous donne l'impression de
nous jeter dans l'inconnu le voyage du
héros nous donne des repères il nous
apprend que tout ce que nous traversons
est normal
ce qui est rassurant il nous permet de
savoir où nous en sommes alors oui
parfois on peut avoir envie de craquer
et quand le héros c'est nous c'est plus
dur la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça fait
complètement partie du processus
le voyage du héros n'est pas une
baguette magique qui fait disparaître le
brouillard c'est un gps qui nous donne
des repères qui nous permettent d'en
sortir plus facilement et plus
sereinement parfois la période de doute
et non seulement normale et saine elle
est surtout totalement nécessaire
c'est elle qui nous permet de trouver
l'énergie du changement et qui pour le
coup permet la fin heureuse
le chemin reste à parcourir mais ce
chemin et maintenant balisés alors la
prochaine fois que vous vous direz je ne
sais pas où j'en suis demandez vous à
quelle étape du voyage du héros vous
êtes demandez vous à quelle étape
vous avez envie d'être et qu'elle suit
vous voulez donner à cette histoire
vous avez maintenant des repères pour
vous orienter